and so i felt like i needed to do
something with much more purpose that
would leave the world in a better place
for my kids and for their kids and it
had to be something that
i would gain a lot of satisfaction from
so that's where i
started to look at the environment and
decided that i would for the rest of my
career
work on solutions to climate change
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and
in media partnership with ctec
technology really has the potential to
make a positive impact around the world
in a lot of areas it even has the
potential to fix
a lot of what we've been breaking over
the years
today i have the honor of sitting with
amy francetic the founder and managing
general partner
of buoyant ventures a new venture fund
in chicago that aims to invest in
digital climate solutions
her career spends over 20 years of high
technology entrepreneurship
private equity and research amy
previously founded and led energized
ventures
a venture fund that invests in digital
energy and industrial automation
she also co-founded and served as ceo of
technology accelerator clean energy
trust
which has invested in dozens of
early-stage clean energy companies
across the midwestern u.s
amy francetic welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you
thank you michael for having me i'm so
excited to be here i'm so impressed at
what you're doing and
happy to share my story thank you very
much and you're calling from illinois
right now
yeah i'm calling in from my home office
in lake forest
illinois on the north shore of lake
michigan amazing
amazing amy if if i try to start listing
everything that you've done
we're not going to have enough in 20
minutes but but just a short highlights
for the context of our conversation
around this idea of sustainability
climate tech
and and clean energy you are the
managing director and co-founder of
energy energized ventures member of
board of directors of clean energy trust
managing director now of buoyant
ventures and
and i'm what i'm curious to dig deep in
these 20 minutes with you as much as we
can
your personal conviction on cleantech
you've done
such incredible things and you've you're
deciding to spend your time now
working on these on these impact
positive technologies and i'm excited to
learn more about
this ecosystem the location you're
choosing to be in and and
everything around there so amy take me
back though to
you know as far back as as you can where
where does this
passion come from sure sure well i
am a huge outdoor and nature enthusiast
so nature and outdoors is my religion
and have used it my whole life as just
honestly a means of coping and
therapy for myself as well i'm a runner
i ran at stanford on the track team um i
have always lived in places where i had
really good access to the outdoors
like all of our family vacations and the
places that are
have a big outdoor component to it and
um
and the the really kind of turning point
and why i turned my attention in my
career because earlier in my career i
was working in the high-tech industry
um and had been an entrepreneur and
started and sold the business
um and it was in the consumer sort of
technology space
but i really turned my focus to the
environment and climate change
after i had two major things happen in
my life one was
my husband and i were trying to start a
family and i
discovered as we were trying to get
started having kids
that actually had cancer so i had to
deal with cancer
early in relatively early in my life
as an adult but but at a rather young
age
and in a lot of my recovery was around
the outdoors like just kind of
like you know being outside and again
like that was super healing for me
and then soon after i dealt with that
and and
um was in remission i got we got
pregnant right away so
i had two girls two wonderful teenage
daughters one who's graduating
high school and going to northwestern i
mentioned
studying sort of computer science and
music there and then another one who's
in high school and so i had a few years
in my career where i
took i wasn't working full-time because
of dealing with the cancer and then
starting a family
and so when i decided to go back into
the workforce which i knew i wanted to
do
i really thought hard about what did i
want to do what did i want
my purpose to be because i felt like i
had this gift of more time on this earth
i had this deep connection to the
environment and the outside and it had
been super healing for me
and now i have these kids you know and
so i felt like i needed to do something
with much more purpose that would leave
the world in a better place
for my kids and for their kids and it
had to be something that i would gain
a lot of satisfaction from so that's
where i started to
look at the environment and decided that
i would for the rest of my career
work on solutions to climate change so
that i could try to make a small
dent you know with the remaining time
that i had here
um on solutions that could be you know
scaled up to sort of really help slow
down climate change address that help us
adapt
better to this changing climate and
incredible
and you know i the the most inspiration
i get from the show is is hearing those
convictions
things like i understood for the rest of
my career i want to be dealing with this
you know i think
it's such a gift that i wish for myself
at some point to have that
strong understanding that this is what
what i want to be doing because this is
what provides
me satisfaction and and positive impact
now you're choosing to be in venture
capital an entrepreneur at heart
is an entrepreneur forever so why why
the decision to make that impact because
you could have
done it while starting startup after
startup but why just to do it
on the venture capital side sure
definitely
very practical reasons so yeah i had
been an entrepreneur earlier in my
life built and sold the company took a
lot out of me to do that
loved it was a great experience um but i
i then started at this technology
accelerator clean energy trust to fund a
lot of companies and i saw the value
of working with a broad set of
businesses especially for
a problem as complicated as climate
change where there is no
silver bullet you know there's no single
solution it's really going to take
deployment and scale up of the
technologies that we have today
it's going to take the invention of new
technologies
it's going to require policy and
regulation
to make sure that those technologies
have a fair
shot at competing in the market it's
going to take alignment
of our political leadership um to
really you know meet this challenge and
so it's so
complicated and um and that if there is
i think better um a better you know
fight
to bring a better weapon to bring as a
portfolio to this fight
because you're going to need all those
different kinds of solutions and so
um so that was sort of number one and
number two i really liked
um you know what the the joy that i got
out of
when you start an organization whether
it is a company
or a technology excel accelerator or a
venture fund those are all
very entrepreneurial endeavors and so
raising money of any kind
is basically sales right so you have to
know how to sell
you don't have to know how to raise
money and raise capital
so i consider buoyant ventures now to be
my fourth startup um
and hopefully my last and hopefully the
thing i'm doing you know from now until
um uh i'm done working but um i think
there's a lot of entrepreneurship in you
know
even if you're not like the ceo of a
startup company
there's a lot of entrepreneurship across
the board in all different facets of
my career but also the ways people can
impact you know beyond sort of like
running a business
so we hear a lot about ai cyber b2b b2c
a lot of consumer products we're seeing
a lot of trends emerging
or you know just increasing and
augmenting over over these last years
clean tech is still not the main
headline
and when i meet the average entrepreneur
usually it's not going to be about clean
tech sustainability clean energy
what's happening in the ecosystem today
i am seeing more but
paint me a picture of the ecosystem what
what are what's happening what's maybe
not happening
sure sure well i've been in the space
for about 15
16 years um i actually count my first
experience working on a clean energy
technology when i worked at stanford
research institute and i was working on
a fuel cell technology in 2005.
it's like my first real exposure to um
clean technology and then you know i've
been in the space since then
um and it has never been a better time
to be a climate tech or a clean energy
entrepreneur it just hasn't like we've
had so many
um opportunities for growth along
over the past you know decade and a half
and i can easily say
now is the best time because of the
amount of support globally
for these issues you know um the amount
of countries that are making commitments
to reduce carbon to make um to adhere to
the paris climate accords
to try to mobilize their
country in in in reducing their their
contributions to climate change
that's happening around the world that
wasn't the case 10 years ago
um the amount of capital that's flowing
into the space is more than there's ever
been
at the later stages so um the companies
that have gotten a little bit of
you know one of the reasons we started
clean energy trust was there was very
little early stage capital for these
hard science
complicated scientific businesses that
take a lot of capital to develop they
take a long time to develop if you're
working on a battery chemistry
or you're working on a solar cell those
are our
technologies that take hundreds of
millions of dollars to develop in
decades right so
so there was very little early stage
venture capital to support those kinds
of businesses which is why we created
back in 2009
uh 2010 clean energy trust along and and
a number of other
technology accelerators got started and
sort of the years after that
but now what we have that we didn't have
before to one of the reasons this is
such a good time
is the public markets are really um
valuing
and rewarding this because of the global
sort of commitment
and because of some regulations that are
causing investors
to really assess the climate impact of
their investments
and to expose the risk the climate risk
in their investment portfolios whether
that's in real
estate that's at risk from weather
events
storm surges droughts fires you know
like you guys are experiencing in
california these terrible wildfire
seasons
um have been so devastating so you know
what it's different everywhere you are
in the world there's different kinds of
weather impacts so it might be a real
estate portfolio it might be
a pure stock portfolio and so a lot of
folks that are trying to use
climate data to analyze you know and
screen out investments from stock
on portfolios and sort of lean into ones
that
that are better equipped to deliver um
growth and alpha outcomes um
in a time frame that is from now say the
next 10 years when we know
people are like even if it took
president trump
and like the last administration to do
everything they could
to prevent us from really kind of
understanding this or committing to it
the rest of the world has come to this
conclusion the business community has
come to this conclusion the investment
community has come to these conclusions
and so now there's a lot of interest and
appetite
in understanding this and the public
markets are starting to reward this as
well so
what that's creating for even these
startup companies is much more capital
in the later stages and that's really
exciting because the valuations are
increasing
the exits are increasing and that money
is finding its way into more venture
funds as well
so as the returns are generated they're
going earlier and earlier
looking for growth from private equity
from venture capital so it's super
exciting
on the capital side it makes it makes a
lot of sense and i'm saying
all of this happening and i have to say
you know from from the young
entrepreneur perspective i think that
one of the bigger issues that we're
facing is that
it's just not as sexy it's as simple as
that it's not necessarily the thing that
that people understand immediately
you're talking about all these
technologies
you know a new type of battery it it
doesn't immediately you know
intercept the heart and the emotions and
causes you know
you know immediate pleasure because you
need to dive
one layer deeper to at least try to
understand so you know i'd love to gain
some inspiration from you
you've seen a lot of these solutions a
lot of these companies what are some
tangible examples of of clean tech
companies or clean energy companies
that you know that i could get excited
by as young entrepreneur so when i
decide to create a startup
i say well this is this is also a cool
avenue
yeah yes so it is complicated right so i
spent when i decided i wanted to
do this i really made a commitment
to deeply understand the energy markets
and energy
is extremely complicated the energy
especially industrial
side of energy is very complex like
because we have
around the world many different ways of
regulating energy in different markets
and pricing it and everything else and
policy has such a major role so you can
never
ignore the role of policy and rule
making and regulations in the energy
markets
it's just it's not as simple as
developing
a consumer software and and putting it
on the internet
and you know getting users that way um
using ad tech to drive
traffic you know and it's just not like
that so so it is
in order to to do this space you have to
have a deep curiosity
you know you have to have a deep passion
and commitment because
uh you will feel stupid many times along
the way
trying to understand the space so just
put that out there
the kinds of things that i think are
really well
positioned now that we have i would say
we have the infrastructure we
have the equipment necessary to drive
um you know almost i would say i'm not
as fixated on getting to 100
clean energy to reduce emissions i think
if we got to 80
clean energy and we still had some
amount of fossil fuels in the mix which
is
practical and feasible we would have
made such a tremendous impact so
i strongly believe that we have already
these solutions what we need to invest
in
um are ways to deploy those technologies
faster
and we can look for ways to optimize
them so that when you think about
transmitting energy between geography
you need you know again a non-sexy thing
to invest in that folks are trying to
figure out is transmission how do you
take an electron that's produced
you know in oklahoma and deliver it to
a load center in you know somewhere in
texas you know like in
dallas and and how do you do that and
how do you do that when you need the
energy like we just saw with the polar
vortex
right like the what happened with the um
the the deep freeze
in texas caused such disruption so those
are non-sexy solutions like transmission
which is not super venture fundable but
um but that can have a huge huge impact
so
the transmission infrastructure we have
it today is more a matter of political
will of building it out
um battery storage solutions and
technology i mean we have gotten so many
gains
already from lithium-ion nobody expected
lithium-ion to be delivering
um such a key part of the storage
solution for electric vehicles
as well as um grid storage and the
the you know all the innovation that
we've had just keeps making it cheaper
and better
and you know just reducing cost
producing so there are new
now new form factors new solid state
batteries
new cheap you know kind of um uh
non-rare earth material batteries
i'm sorry if this is getting too geeky
for your audience but there's a lot of
innovation now because we've kind of
like
squeezed as much as we can out of
lithium ion so now we need to look at
the next
types of technologies but that is going
to be super valuable
when it comes to electrified
transportation like without a doubt like
countries around the world are saying
okay we're phasing out internal
combustion engine vehicles so
there's going to be a huge huge need for
high-performance long-duration
batteries for these vehicles and at some
point lithium-ion is going to reach its
limit and so there's going to be need
for invention there
and then when you think about the grid
and being able to store energy
and replace what we've kind of been
using natural gas to do which is to be
these peaker plants and to be um
energy when we need it in a pinch and
like you saw what happened in
texas batteries would be a really great
alternative to that so there's going to
be
a lot of requirements for battery
innovation we're seeing some really
really cool things
it's not what i'm investing in i'm
investing in more of your background and
your space which is
software that can optimize the
performance of this equipment
and squeeze a little better performance
out of these solutions
or can use data to drive decisions
around how you deploy
site and operate this equipment and
maybe also how you um analyze and
measure risk
so i also saw in your background that
you're working with hippo so
one of our first investments right now
for buoyant is actually in
a weather risk insurance company we
haven't closed it yet so i won't name it
but the opportunity to use data
around weather to drive some kind of
financial instrument
that can address risk so that when you
have this exposure to an extreme weather
event you can actually have some
insurance protection
that could be super valuable for folks
that are most exposed
like some of the un overlooked
communities that have the most financial
exposure to
these kinds of weather events they don't
have the savings and the means to sort
of respond to it so if you could have a
insurance solution that would pay out in
these settings that would be very very
beneficial so again like you have
batteries you know you have transmission
the nuts and bolts of this but then you
also have a lot of innovation
around using data to drive better
decisions and to drive
um solutions that we can use uh for
climate change
right and what i'm hearing you say you
know there's so much low hanging fruit
around with it with incredible solutions
that's a that's benny he is my
positive impact and and you know it's
it's there's so many lying fruits around
even software solutions that that people
from all backgrounds in the tech
industry
can can leverage and one of the things
that i'm also hearing you say is that
you know it's not just that we know that
it's something that we should be working
on but
it's becoming a necessity and and
entering in a more connected and
globalized world
the current solutions just aren't going
to be enough to allow for all the
amazing innovation that's happening to
be facilitated
whether it be in electricity and in in
infrastructure and so we we need
these technologies not just for the
sustainability of the planet but also
for the sustainability of innovation
right
yep yeah for sure and i think you know
what individuals
can do and we're starting to see a lot
of folks that are looking at offsets
you know as a means of sort as as
companies make these pledges
to decarbonize as countries make these
pledges
um the really key thing is to look at
removing carbon
from your energy sources from your
supply chain from your operations of
your business
but then you know being able to purchase
and use offsets to
get you the rest of the way there
because it's really hard to get to
like a zero carbon or net zero
um or carbon neutral position without
doing some kind of offsets however
that you know one offset is not like the
other and they're not the same so
um you know so there's and there's also
a lot of inflation
right now in the space and there's also
a lot of fraud so we're looking again
at software at blockchain as a means of
sort of
creating a better certified process for
exchanging
offsets for certifying them and then
making sure folks aren't double counting
them
but then also valuing them so that you
could see how one is sort of a little
better than the other
um and for folks to be able to purchase
those with some
better assurance that what they're
really doing is achieving the goal
because otherwise you get into this sort
of um false sense of security right like
i'm purchasing all these offsets and
taking care of
my carbon problem but then you keep you
know
consuming and emitting and doing
everything it's like energy efficiency
the more efficient like our
devices get the more we use them and we
think it doesn't matter so it's kind of
the same thing with offset so we have to
do a much better job
of understanding um how to decarbonize
and what
markets there are for these kinds of um
solutions
amy thank you so much for these 20
minutes it was so enjoyable
and very inspirational and i know how
busy you are so very thank you for for
joining me
and there are so many more things i
wanted to ask but but i called the show
20 minute leaders so i have to abide by
that but i do have three questions about
about amy
and not about clean tech and not about
buoyancy but
going back to middle school days your
childhood what what fascinated you as a
kid what was your favorite subject
science without a doubt i just love
science i love the discovery
process i love the labs i mean i just
i couldn't get enough of it it was just
exciting to me
i'm honestly a frustrated i'm a science
junkie but i didn't pursue science in
college i went the business route you
know and so i think
i look back along the way i'm like why
did i do that i don't know like how i
kind of like straight away
but that's why i love what i do because
i get to satisfy that curiosity um
and some inspiration along your journey
personally professionally
a type of role model for you well i just
have you know women in this space who
have um
you know raised their own funds like i'm
doing now and who
are uh have been pioneers in the field
there are some really great women and
whose stories are starting to be told
and uh you know whether it's kind of the
original gangsters of the venture
community in
your area like teresa gao and some of
the other folks i mean i really love
nancy fund in myspace i think she's
really terrific
but then i think other people like i
just you know
i cannot get over the fact being that
i'm in chicago and every once in a while
he turns up on television like barack
obama's like incredible
story and person and leader and so lucky
that he's still
young and active and engaged and doing
things and i just
sometimes i just stop and go man that
guy like
and his wife and what they did to
overcome you know all the odds to be the
first
you know african-american president in
the united states i just
that kind of pioneering spirit and
conviction and personal
integrity is very inspiring to me i love
it
and what are three words that you would
use to describe yourself
um curious endlessly curious um
super you know enthusiastic like i
i love to fall in love with technologies
and solutions and innovation
um and i think grateful i'm just so so
grateful
you know i feel like that's a really key
thing is to be very grateful for i feel
very fortunate that i have
um everything that i have in my life and
my family and my daughters and my
husband
and friends and you know colleagues and
people that have believed in me in my
career to help me
do what i've done could never have
gotten things you know accomplish what i
have without
a lot of support along the way so i
think i just always want to be very very
grateful
for that amy thank you so much this is
michael you're so great at this thank
you for having me i really appreciate it
you